[Música]
eu sou o primeiro é um grande prazer
estar aqui com vocês hoje como foi muito
bem falado nessa o filho da também
só que eu não sou da puc minas aqui de
belo horizonte
eu sou lá de poços de caldas no interior
de minas é só pra entender alguém aqui
conhece poços de caldas
se vocês forem para poços de caldas
fique na minha casa teve lá só pra
gostoso foi recomendado tranquilidade
com decote já barak
e aí pessoal hoje estava assistindo às
palestras de todo mundo aprendendo muito
quantas histórias inspiradoras quantas
histórias incríveis
sou formado em administração e eu queria
contar pra vocês hoje como que encontrei
meu propósito como a gente fala de
futuro sem falar do nosso passado do
nosso presente eo nosso futuro vou
contar um pouquinho pra vocês uma
história
a primeira coisa é quando a gente pensa
em futuro né
o futuro já pararam pra pensar que ele
sempre parece ele foi feito para ser
melhor sempre o futuro é o que vai ser
melhor
quando você está no ensino fundamental o
ensino médio é melhor quando você está
no médio ou superior na faculdade vai
ser melhor ou quando você está no
estágio grande sonho é efetivação só que
a minha história começou um pouco
diferente ea minha história quando a
gente volta lá ela começa quando eu
morava em são josé dos campos
não sei se alguém aqui no estado de são
paulo e aí tinha uma coisa engraçada
quando um pouquinho né das referências
eu morava em um bairro lá que os meus
amigos eles tinham um baita orgulho de
ter parente bandido era só para
engraçado porque eu me sentia meio
isolado placar mas eu não tenho parente
bandido então eu sofria bullying por
isso achava que era super bizarro isso
pula catraca do ônibus é ela responde a
diversão hoje têm celular antes pela
catraca era era de um esporte que a
gente fazia e eu achava super comum
quando tinha linchamento
porque às vezes quando lá
drama chegava no bairro e pulando de
casa em casa né e aí a sabedoria popular
que a gente fez começamos a ficar na rua
aí a gente pegava um cara pulando na rua
a gente pegava esse cara é amarrar
buscar no poste e ela é super normal
isso
agora imagina isso é pra criança de 8
anos de idade vai crescendo é com essa
situação diz não mudei pra poços de
caldas
saí de são josé a lipo agora vai ser
diferente né
poxa aí chegou uma situação que era
super normal engravidar aos 16 anos e é
muito bizarro assim porque quando a
menina não engravidava com 16 anos ela
ficava super mal falada no bairro estava
não essa menina tem problema é tem
certeza e é engraçado lutando quente
machista nem sempre a culpa da mulher
nem tudo e vários amigos eles entrando
no mundo das drogas começando a entrar
no tráfico porque era super legal cara
porque não quer ser chefe da boca né
uma galera galera galera galera alegando
na escola na mão da escola porque o cara
pra que eu vou largar mão da escola
porque eu vou fazer isso que a escola
não tem sentido e também todo mundo
queria colocar empresa paulo e fazer
esquema porque o sonho da galera eu
trabalhava lá e é só juntando documentos
juntando documento e o sonho era que
daria dez anos quando ele fosse mandado
embora ele colocava um processo na
justiça e é esse processo é vender pelo
que sei lá uns 30 a 50 mil reais
agora queria falar um pouco pra vocês né
quando você sonha com um futuro na
realidade dessa você pensa em um futuro
com a cabeça tão torta assim com tantas
referências estranhas e aí qualquer
consequência disso né eu pra mim todo
mundo era filhinha de papai
então todo mundo na frente papai isso me
fazia ter muita raiva de quem tinha
grana eu achava que ameace a miséria a
culpa da miséria do outro então adorava
jogar bola contra o pessoal da escola
particular porque adorava bater na
galera era um jeito totalmente sem
sentido totalmente sem lógica porque pra
mim tudo que eu tinha aprendido e só
quero certo e era bizarro uma coisa
porque não sei se vocês enxergam aquele
borrão
lá do lado direito superior esse aqui é
o meu bairro la em poços de caldas
chamada de maria imaculada
é um apelido carinhoso que é maria e
maconhados e aqui do lado esquerdo ea
puc
eu achava muito bizarro isso claro
porque uma imaculada uma uma maculado
para os íntimos
ele tinha mais de mil habitantes e se
sabe quantas pessoas estavam na puc
nenhuma então era o muro era uma
barreira invisível porque cara porque eu
não posso ir de lá lá por quê
e aí foi indo né como é que o futuro né
jovem assim se eu ficasse forte e ver a
segurança
só que era forte estava nu na capa da
gaita se eu falasse muito ea ser
vendedor né até porque é só falar que
você vendedor
hoje eu topasse estudar à noite e as e
peão rodar 12 por 36 pegar peso né
se eu largasse a mão de tudo e ajudar
ele haverá servente ajudar a galera na a
pegar lage se eu fosse mais ou menos
trabalheira trabalharia no supermercado
e foi onde eu comecei com o meu primeiro
emprego aos 16 anos eo problema gente
não é é o trabalho não tem o menor
problema a mês e pacoteiros e operador
de caixa repositor problema é a forma
se você não tem sonhos se você não pensa
no seu futuro nessa idade
isso vai ser o seu limite você não
consegue enxergar possibilidades pra
você e teve um dia que seja marcou muito
a minha vida porque nessa época eu
lembro que eu estava de folga né
dodô san michel que elas o mercado
trabalhava e eu cheguei mais ou menos
acordei às 7 horas da manhã não sei
porque na época em foco a gente acaba
fazendo isso né
acorda mais cedo e eu fui tomar europeu
no café da manhã foi como eu e meu pão
com manteiga e aí quando fui procurar um
pão não tinha troco de 10 centavos
porque o pão naquela época 10 centavos
aí eu procurei minha carteira e não
tinha
aí eu procurei no armário não tinha
aí eu procurei em tudo quanto é canto
cara não tinha uma porcaria de um pão
não tinha porcaria de uma moeda de 10
centavos cara eu chorei velho
nós e não tem noção cara eu cheguei não
é possível que minha vida inteira vai
ser uma porcaria
não é possível que eu não consigo sair
desse ciclo e foi bem na época que meus
pais eles se separaram então estava bem
tensa situação e enquanto eu chorava
mandei um prato de arroz feijão às 7
horas da manhã enquanto chorava comendo
a lágrima no prato de molho aquela coisa
assim
ali eu tomei a decisão valeu preciso
tomar uma eu preciso mudar que era
preciso de uma filosofia eu preciso de
alguma coisa pra fazer essa diferença e
aí eu falei cara eu vou mudar minha vida
e não vai ser só minha vida eu vou mudar
a vida de vários jovens que estão na
mesma situação que eu tô aí nesse dia
foi engraçado que eu lembrei gosto muito
de rap gosta de rap ópera gosta de tudo
com a música eu não sei quem gosta de
racionais em aparte almoço e fala né que
tenha fé porque até no chão na flor e eu
falei cara
mano mano brown é gênio caro mano brown
está falando comigo nessa música
ele falou cara da e aí foi doido porque
quando eu resolvi tomar uma atitude
diferente
mais cedo o que eu pensava na sexta
estranha que nasceu prouni
eu lembro até hoje da da opinião da
galera de prouni cara por que que eu vou
fazer a prova no final de semana que
elas é tocar a galera vai jogar bola
só que aqui eu falei cara essa é a
primeira ação que eu vou fazer que vai
mudar tudo
fui bem em bolsa de 100% e é engraçado
porque nessa época eu tinha uma visão
super conturbada de universitário que eu
queria muito esse cara não sei se
conhece american pae cara é meu sonho
para buscar essa fazem festa e meu sonho
na faculdade na puc é uma festa que a
galera dançar se na cadeira
falei cara um dia ainda vou fazer isso
da minha viu então achava muito da hora
esse mundo universitário deve ser massa
ou então tinha um programa para esse
programa e não sei se todo mundo conhece
tá vendo aquela galera ligada à direita
no caso de vocês à esquerda os
universitários
cara eu ficava em casa falei mas esses
caras são muito da hora porque os caras
eles ajudam silvio santos cara e os
filhos
os caras sempre ver citar então eu vou
ser universitário porque essa galera
inteligente
aí quando eu entrei na faculdade
escolhida mas mesmo assim mas na época
era a grande visão então o cara da
american pae imagina a cara olha o lugar
mágico
a faculdade você só tem festa e você tem
o cara de terno cara roxa que embora a
cara de terno
eu queria um terno e entrei cá comecei a
fazer a administração eu percebi que era
da hora k universidade o negócio negócio
de doido e foi muito louco porque lá foi
um dos maiores choques que eu tive na
vida porque eu conheci uma menina que
ela gostava de ração para o cachorro
dela era maior do que o salário da minha
mãe o meu irmão juntos e sabe o que quer
o mais louco de tudo ela era gente boa
aquilo foi um choque porque lembrei cara
então quer dizer que não é tudo rico que
é desgraçado
foi muito louco porque eu fiquei eu
entrei em parafuso cara falou mano a
mano quanta gente que bate sem que não
foi que ele nega
quanta gente que eu sem querer
tive a atitude inapropriada durante o
jogo de futebol de futebol porque me
falaram que só tinha aversão ao lembrar
que eu tinha uns primos que eram bem
desgraçados também quer então não é
grana não é grana não é grana ea gente
às vezes escuta muito legal falando
sobre bolhas né
às vezes você escuta tanto na única
versão que você acha que a conversão é
certa e isso não existe e aí comecei
cara da hora assistindo aula para você
que tem a litorina universitário não
estava tendo festa não era tão
inteligente ainda mas não está faltando
prática e aí foi a segunda ação que eu
tive que mudou tudo
entrar na puc júnior de 600 alunos 4
toparam cada
eu pensei cara se de 604 toparam é claro
que percebo o negócio é porque só 0,6
por cento tiveram desses caras aqui e aí
foi doido porque quando entrei na época
junina aqui a foto do menino
que coisa feia caso ainda lá na empresa
júnior se tenha impressora ali atrás e
aqui eu ea camila camila era presidente
da empresa júnior
seu cabeleireiro e sei que têm fazendo
sucesso ali que os menininhos celular
para mostrar que é inteligente tem que
mostrar o celular que ele dê flip que
era da hora pra caramba e aqui aconteceu
negócio
a cana nessa época eu tinha passado no
concurso era concursado sonho de quase
todo mundo da minha sala e acontecer o
negócio louco a camila uma empresa
contratou ela porque percebeu que cara
pessoas da empresa juros são boas de
serviço são melhores dos meus alunos que
só assistem aula e aí eu falei cara que
eu faço agora eu largo um concurso
público que eu ganhava mil reais só de
alimentação nunca comi tanto minha vida
nossa cozinha muito muito muito orgulho
da mãe porque o filho concursado é o
orgulho da mãe falava pra todo mundo
opel filho começava a colocar e aí que o
fez a essa é uma escolha ea outra
trabalhar na empresa júnior no final de
semana sem ganhar um centavo
sábado domingo até a madrugada a
escolher é muito óbvio né
claro que eu entrei no médio e aí entra
no beijo foi muito louco porque que
várias questões não pôde me tornar mais
brasileiro pôde conhecer vários lugares
do brasil primeira vez que a viagem de
avião na vida cara imagina aquele
moleque aquele moleque não sonhava que
estava viajando de avião e aí como foi
muito forte essa questão de empreender a
empresa julho comecei minha própria
empresa começou a dar certo cara a gente
começou a ganhar grana da hora de
setembro aquela viajando
só que aí eu lembrei daquele menino que
estava lá no ensino médio que ninguém
acreditava e junto com a minha esposa de
criança esposa linda linda maravilhosa
criamos um pré escola a partir de uma
oportunidade que eu tive com o programa
red bull uma pico em que eles escolheram
dez jovens do brasil para apoiar para
tirar a idéia do papel e nessa época eu
já estava muito nessa questão cara a
gente tem que fazer
a ação é o mais importante e aí criamos
em pré escola para trabalhar várias
questões que esse jovem que ele não
tinha acesso ele não sabia como
funcionava para preparar o jovem para a
vida entrando um pouco na imprensa
depois disso a gente pode ajudar mais de
650 jovens em 18 cidades que ninguém
liga a cidade de 25 às vezes de 2 mil
habitantes cidade que não tem nem
farmácia
só que a gente vai nesses lugares é um
lugar que ninguém vai e foi bacana
porque a gente começou a crescer com em
pré escola começou a ter um caminho é de
reconhecimento por causa dessa ação e o
ano passado foi selecionado para o
programa leader of américas energia teve
imagina cara um moleque que estava
batendo na galera e os estados unidos
que era de graça até guarda uma grande
compra - perguntando pra mim porque
adoro e aí foi muito massa porque quando
você começa a ter isso começa a ter
noção da importância do som e da
importância de começar a ter futuro
tive algumas das experiências mais
incríveis da minha vida cara imagina se
eu falasse a mulher de 15 anos que ele
encontra um dia o senhor da microsoft
queria na amazon que ele ia no
aniversário dele no cirque du soleil é
caro nem saber como falar dos negócios
então imagina a cara ea semana agora é
por causa do ir lá e eu acabei de ser
selecionado num programa chamado o flip
o único brasileiro de 22 jovens do
brasil do do mundo para falar sobre
liderança jovem para compartilhar
oportunidades e a fundação lemann acabou
de fazer um processo de seleção para
fazer mestrado fora do brasil nos
estados unidos e 800 pessoas
a minha carinha bonita aqui ó então
imagina que esse moleque
[Aplausos]
[Música]
imagina a cara imagina o milagre cara da
ação esse moleque vai estudar em harvard
cara eu vou não tenho dúvida disso
porque quando se está acostumado a tomar
pancada a viver a vida no nível hardy
você não está acostumado com as pessoas
que ajudem
é só mais um sonho e aí é louco quando
comecei a refletir sobre isso eu percebi
que a filosofia da minha vida é isso
aqui
a partir do momento que eu tenho o
primeiro passo a partir do momento que
eu comecei a fazer tudo mudou
e aí a gente começa a pensar em futuro
né é o que eu penso de futuro que que é
futuro gente o futuro pra mim é eu sou e
todo dia com o futuro em que a gente
tenha um baú um país mais doador
então nós queremos um projeto chamado
faça a diferença em que a gente está
pegando ex bolsistas do prouni que
tiveram a vida transformada para
investir no jovem está na primeira turma
a gente vai chegar no brasil inteiro e
quando eu sonho com o futuro eu sonho
com o país com o mundo e que as
oportunidades sejam para todos quem a
mesma oportunidade que chega na capital
chega na cidade de 1.500 habitantes
chega na cidade que não só tem estrada
de terra à cidade que a gente vai dar
uma palestra tinha uma cobra no meio da
sala é literalmente uma cobra que
bizarro negócio desse
então eu eu sonho também um com país em
que muitas vezes esse jovem que ele tem
tecnologia ele tem contatos
eu soube que esse jovem tem amigos
eu sei que esse jovem tenha suporte
quando muitas vezes o professor não
acredita nele os pais não acreditam nele
muitas vezes ele não acredita a gente
acredita cara a gente tá lá se ele tá
afim de chorar a gente chora junto
porque por mais tecnologia que a gente
tenha tá faltando o olho no olho tá
faltando carinho tá faltando a gente
fazer a nossa parte está faltando nós
agimos e o que eu faço todo dia que eu
trabalho todo dia acorda às 5 horas da
manhã é para que o privilégio de alguns
ele seja direito de todos muito obrigado
pessoal
[Aplausos]